savez-vous quel prénom peut-on donner ou
pas à sa progéniture que dit précisément
la loi et comment at elle évolué jusque
dans les années 90 c'était une loi très
ancienne qui encadraient le choix des
prénoms français
une loi datant de 1803 est établi à
l'époque par napoléon bonaparte
c'est une loi qui est une loi de
l'époque révolutionnaire qui est du onze
germinal an 11 et qui prévoit qu'on ne
peut donner comme prénom à ses enfants
que les prénoms en usage dans les
différents calendriers et les noms des
personnages connus dans l'antiquité le
calendrier chrétien faisait donc partie
des références mais aussi le calendrier
persan et républicains les sadi une
fille logo était donc accepté et pour
les prénoms bretons c'était une autre
histoire
en 1975 par exemple le prénom de
plusieurs enfants de cette famille
bretonne était refusé par
l'administration
il est certain qu'à génocide dans la
mesure où on empêche les gens de porter
les prénoms bretons si sombre temps de
parler leur langue
à cette époque la loi c'était pourtant
largement assoupli
mais la validité d'un prénom restait
encore à l'appréciation de l'officier
d'état civil qui pouvait le refuser s'il
le jugeait trop ridicule
un choix assez subjectif donc en 1991
contre toute attente l'administration
valider ce prénom périphériques suite
avoué j'ai demandé à la maman 6 elle se
trompait pas si c'était pas médéric ce
n'est pas frédéric elle m'a dit non non
non non non c'est périphériques et je
vais ligne ce sera jamais accepté par
l'état civil
or ça l'a été pas périphérique sud mais
périphérique a été acceptée et en 1993
une nouvelle loi ouvre la voie à encore
plus de liberté
dorénavant l'officier d'état civil doit
obligatoirement inscrire le prénom
choisi par les parents quel que soit
l'écran tricité mais s'il juge que
l'intérêt de l'enfant est en jeu il peut
encore alerté le procureur de la
république qui décidera ou pas de
l'invalidé il encore une fois tout est
une question de subjectivité
après les zébulons et autres albator le
très chic décalé à la mode ce sont les
marques déjà 500 chanel en france et 3
ikea qui a été choisi parce qu'ils ont
eu énormément de mal à avoir cette
enfant au même titre qu'ils avaient eu
énormément de mal à monter les meubles
si ikea a été validé par
l'administration lés robocop lucifer ou
adolf hitler ont pas connu le même sort
[Musique]